ladies gentlemen Vice President Al Gore
Thank You mr. president it is indeed a
great in singular honor for me to be on
this campus again and particularly under
these circumstances and I congratulate
you dr. Cohen on your transformative
leadership of this institution not least
on matters affecting the environment I
also want to express my personal
gratitude to dr. ed Rubin and to say to
Ed Rubin and his colleagues at the IPCC
how grateful this world is for the two
decades of work these distinguished
scientists at the top of their
respective fields have done in a
collaborative and impressive and
unprecedented way to a chairman of the
board of trustees David Shapiro to the
members of the board of trustees and may
I mention three by name who are close
personal friends Teresa Heinz Kerry who
invited me to come and dedicate the
Heinz Center some years ago as mentioned
but to who was by then already a
longtime friend and fellow environmental
advocate and a person for whom I have
boundless respect Cynthia Friedman a
very close friend to my wife tipper and
me and a leader and a founder of and a
very important program to bring young
people into contact with public service
and to my close friend and business
partner ray lane who as a member of your
board of trustees invited me to come
here today I've enjoyed working with ray
lane and have learned a great deal from
him to the other distinguished guests
who are present and I don't know if he's
present or not but I wanted to take a
moment just to say a special word about
one of your professors who has touched
the hearts and spirits of our nation dr.
randy pausch in
a hero in this country
ray lane told the graduating class in
Doha about the motto your heart is in
the work and dr. randy pausch his heart
is with all of us and I am very grateful
for the opportunity to have read what
he's written I am Al Gore I used to be
the next president of the United States
of America I I don't think that's
particularly funny you know put
yourselves in my position for a moment I
flew on Air Force two for eight years
and now I have to take off my shoes to
get on an airplane just one quick story
to illustrate the emotional whiplash of
that experience not long after I left my
job in the White House my wife tipper
and I were driving from our home in
Nashville Tennessee to a small farm we
have 50 miles away and we were driving
ourselves
and I know that sounds like a little
thing to most of you but I looked in the
rearview mirror and all of a sudden it
it just hit me there was no motorcade
back there you've heard of phantom limb
pain this was a rented Ford Taurus and
it was close to dinnertime and so we
looked for a place to eat and got off
the interstate highway and found a
Shoney's restaurant a low-cost family
restaurant chain and we walked in sat
down at the booth and the waitress came
over and made a big commotion over
tipper and then took our order and went
to the couple in the booth sitting next
to us and she lured her voice so much I
had to really strain to hear what she
was saying she said yes that's former
Vice President Al Gore and his wife
tipper and the man said he's come down a
long way yes
it was an epiphany um the very next day
continuing a true story I flew to the
continent of Africa to Nigeria to give a
speech in lagos on energy policy and i
began my speech by telling that story
that had just occurred the day before in
Tennessee and I told it in terms
identical to the ones i've used here
shoneys low-cost family restaurant chain
tip and i were driving ourselves what
the man said and they laughed and after
giving my speech I went out to the
airport to catch a flight back to the
United States and I fell asleep on the
plane until in the middle of the night
we landed on the Azores Islands for
refueling him they opened the door and I
walked out onto the platform to get some
fresh air and to my surprise a man was
waving a piece of paper and running
toward the plane across the runway
yelling at the top of his lungs call
Washington call Washington and I thought
to myself how could this be it's the
middle of the night we're in the middle
of the Atlantic Ocean what in the world
could be wrong in Washington and then I
remembered it could be a bunch of things
but what it turned out to be was that
one of the wire service reporters in
Nigeria had already written a story
about my speech there and it had already
been printed in newspapers across
America it was printed here in
Pittsburgh and my staff was very
concerned because the story began former
Vice President Al Gore announced in
Nigeria yesterday quote my wife tipper
and i have opened a low-cost family
restaurant
names Shoney's and we are running it
ourselves before I could get back to the
US the late night television comics Jay
Leno and David Letterman who are
sometimes not very funny had already had
a field day with this one of them had me
in a big white chef's hat and tipper was
yelling at me scribbling furiously one
more cheeseburger with fries three days
later I got a nice long handwritten
letter from my friend and former partner
Bill Clinton saying congratulations on
the new restaurant out we like to
celebrate each other's successes in life
now I'm a recovering politician on about
step 9 and I was thinking of how long it
has been since i sat in the seats that
these graduates now occupy symbolically
39 years ago I remember a beautiful day
my friends the joy I felt my family what
a wonderful occasion there is one thing
I have literally this is true absolutely
no memory of and that is who it was that
gave the commencement address that day I
really have no idea and I daresay many
of you will share that same experience
years from now unless I've successfully
tricked you in any case into remembering
this is a campus that has provided great
leadership for our nation and for our
world in confronting what I regard as
the most serious crisis our civilization
has ever confronted see our magazine has
named Carnegie Mellon as one of the
schools that gets it researchers here
like a driven are leading the world's
effort to understand ways that co2 can
be captured and safely stored your
undergraduate and
environmental engineering programs are
consistently ranked among the very top
in the entire country your environment
across the curriculum initiative allows
all students to integrate an
understanding of the environment into
their respective courses of study and
you have been walking the walk by
becoming the largest purchaser of wind
retail purchaser of wind power in the
United States of America prompting other
colleges and universities in
Pennsylvania and around the country to
make similar commitment you have also
installed solar array systems built
leed-certified buildings and have built
green roofs and have demonstrated other
new technology innovations that have
become important as part of the nation's
and the world's response your recycling
program has grown your leadership in
every field has become extremely
important and significant and it is not
an accident that this city were you that
you call home has itself been a
renaissance city renewing the commitment
to leadership and science and technology
for which it was known in an earlier
area era and for which it is known yet
again pittsburgh has the largest
concentration of green buildings and is
adding to the many lists of first that
it is known for one of the first winners
of the nobel prize in chemistry more
than a hundred years ago svante
arrhenius did calculations with pen and
paper and after 10,000 equations
calculated that if we doubled the amount
of co2 in the Earth's atmosphere the
world's average temperature would go up
by several degrees his calculations were
considered speculative for a long time
but the most recent work of the IPCC
actually is quite consistent with what
are he Nia's predicted more than a
century ago he based his work on
accurate infrared observations by samuel
pierpont langley who in turn used an
instrument invented in 1890 right here
in Pittsburgh John Alfred Brashear that
story is not well known but I did a bit
of research to find out more about him
and dr. Brashear was a top-flight
scientists and inventors and inventor
and one of the stories written about him
is that he cut a large hole in his roof
in South Side Pittsburgh and poked a
handmade telescope out the hole in his
roof and invited his neighbors to come
into his bedroom and explore the heavens
on those rare clear nights in those days
when the suit belching steel mills were
closed down for the holidays it prompted
me to realize how grateful I am to my
own family for their patience with me
for all the work I've put into this and
I have told tipper that whatever other
sacrifices I've asked the family to make
I have not yet cut a hole in the roof of
the bedroom a plaque on Brashear script
reads we have loved the stars too fondly
to be fearful of the night I want to ask
all of you to take that thought with you
as you leave this graduating ceremony we
have had in the United States of America
to special generations in our history
that appreciated the promise of the
future so much that they overcome
overcame all fear
to create a new era the generation of
our founders won the struggle for
independence and in its aftermath
created the basis for freedom in the
modern world and then in the middle of
the 20th century the generation we
consistently refer to as the greatest
generation one the struggle against
global fascism in Europe and in the
Pacific both simultaneously and then
finding upon their return that they had
gained moral authority as a result of
their struggle and a capacity for
long-term vision that they had not taken
with them into the battlefield they set
out again to remake the world
african-americans who had been a part of
that cause came back and said we will no
longer put up with segregation Jackie
Robinson 20 years before he was breaking
new ground in professional baseball was
court-martialed in 1945 for refusing to
go to the back of the bus we had Native
Americans who helped to win the war
struggle and came back and broke new
ground women who had helped to produce
the goods and material for victory said
we are going to insist upon equality and
that generation created the Marshall
Plan lifting their defeated adversaries
from the battlefield and helping them
march toward renewal freedom and
prosperity they created the United
Nations and the other institutions that
bought us decades of peace and
prosperity you I hope and expect will be
called upon to be part of the third hero
generation in American history because
this moment of your graduation sees the
United States of America poised to
reclaim its rightful place as the leader
of the world as our world confronts this
unprecedented challenge
we face a planetary emergency the
concentrations of global warming
pollution have been rising at an
unprecedented pace and have now given
the planet of fever you know the famous
opening sentence of a tale of two cities
these are the best of time they were the
best of times they were the worst of
times well we face now if I could share
with you briefly a tale of two planets
Earth and Venus are almost exactly the
same size and have precisely the same
amount of carbon but the difference is
here on earth for hundreds of millions
of years through the processes of
biology and geology the co2 has been
pulled out of the atmosphere and
sequestered deep in the ground in the
form of coal oil natural gas and other
fossil fuels on Venus that those
processes were very different and left
most most of the co2 in the atmosphere
so as a consequence the average
temperature here is about 59 degrees
Fahrenheit worldwide and on Venus is 875
degrees fahrenheit above the melting
point of let that story is relevant to
our current global strategy of taking as
much of that carbon out of the ground as
quickly as possible burning it very
inefficiently and leaving it as
poisonous dangerous residue in the
Earth's atmosphere but because the
Industrial Revolution has given us a
suite of technologies that have been
constructed for 240 years since the
first C mention we now face an
unprecedented challenge in science
engineering and in public policy the
Industrial Revolution was stimulated in
part by England's recognition that trees
were disappearing and they could no
longer rely on that fuel source well
there is a parallel reality today as oil
reaches a hundred and twenty eight
dollars a barrel and the supplies of
coal though abundant in the ground are
now not delivered on
I'm and the price of all fossil fuels is
rising dramatically we just as at the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
when your counterparts helped to create
a new era we now find that solar energy
particularly in the form of
concentrating solar thermal power and
wind energy and distributed power
generation and geothermal energy and the
series of other new innovations have now
reached the stage where we can replace
every electron and every BTU from the
fossil fuel sources without missing a
beat but we need one ingredient that you
represent we need political will we need
your dedication we need your hearts
there is an African proverb that says if
you want to go quickly go alone if you
want to go far go together we have to go
far quickly and we need your help to do
it we have everything we need to get
started with the sole exception of
political will but as you know here in
Pittsburgh and especially at Carnegie
Mellon University political will is a
renewable resource good luck Godspeed
congratulations to all of you
you